hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
cardinal virtues discussed in plato's
republic book 4 is translated as
temperance it's called so fro sunay in
the Greek so sometimes moderation
there's a number of other ways that we
can render it and it's not only
discussed in republic book 4 it's also
discussed in other places for example
the dialogue the karma days here we're
going to focus just on this particular
treatment and when we look at the three
virtues that Plato says function within
the soul and function within the city in
terms of the parts of the city and
thereby form you might say the
components or the conditions for the
fourth virtue of justice temperance is a
little bit different than the others how
so
well we have to ask ourselves a question
whenever we're thinking of the Platonic
psychology where is something located
right so what part of the city or what
part of the soul needs to be temperate
and unlike wisdom unlike courage Plato
says the entire city needs it they may
not need it in exactly the same
wäôre it exactly the same degree but
they all do in fact require it in order
to do their own job well and not
interfere with other people's jobs and
in order for the entire city to be one
cohesive functioning unity which is
better for everybody within the city so
as opposed to like courage which doesn't
need to be possessed by the ordinary
person on the street the craftsperson as
Plato will call him all parts of the
city the the Guardians the the ordinary
people the craftspeople and the soldiers
or the lesser Guardians auxiliaries all
of them need to be temperate all of them
need to be so thrown in Greek and he
talks about this as being a kind of
harmony or Concord between the parts
there are some some musical analogies
going on that are very clearly intended
by Plato he also uses the term order or
orderliness and the Greek term that he
uses there that we translate is cosmos
which is quite interesting because you
know we think of all cosmos that's the
universe right for the Greeks cosmos is
universe insofar as it's not just a
crazy mess out there but is ordered and
cosmos also has the connotation of a
kind of beauty of proportionality things
all being in their place if they are
dynamic rather than static functioning
the way that they ought to so the so
firm person the temperate person is in a
certain respect a beautiful person
insofar as their their soul is ordered
properly so there is this harmony going
on and and Plato will bring up the issue
of another closely related term self
mastery in Greek and Katya often opposed
to a crash'
Razia which which Socrates has a rather
unusual view on which we're not going to
go into a car SIA is when we know what
the good thing is but we don't do it or
we know what the bad thing is and we do
it
self-mastery and katya is when we know
what the good thing is and we make
ourselves do it even though we might be
tempted or impelled or all sorts of
other inducements may be brought on us
to do something different we we force
ourselves to do that and Plato says well
you know this is kind of a silly thing
he's joking around a little bit here at
first he says that you know we the
phrase master of our self is an
absurdity he who is master of himself it
always would also be subject to himself
and he who is subject to himself would
be master the same person is spoken of
in all these expressions and then he
says how can we understand this properly
well the self must have parts the soul
must be divided into different things
that have different functions and can be
in accord with each other or disk or
ting or in conflict with each other so
he also says this only makes sense if we
can think of some of these parts as
being higher or lower or worse and
better and within his City there is
indeed a hierarchy with the wisdom
holding and exercising guardians at the
top a very small class who you know have
to go through a very rigorous education
in order to get there nobody is forcing
them to you know join that that as a
matter of fact some of them may wash out
then we have the larger class of the
Guardians the soldiers the ones who
protect and then we have the much much
larger class of the those who are
producers those who actually get to
enjoy a higher standard of living in
certain respects materially than either
of the higher classes and they are in
some respect you know lower or worse now
what does Temperance actually deal with
doesn't deal with fear that's courage is
domain right as a matter of fact it
doesn't even really deal with like say
curiosity which
zoom would fall within the realm of
wisdom it deals with things that the
Greeks called appetites or desires at
the Thule eye and these are appetites or
desires generally for bodily things like
avoiding pain right avoiding toil
enjoying here's the other thing
pleasures bodily pleasures like eating
and having intoxicants of different
sorts they really just had wine as the
main thing they talked about drinking
and they presumably mean drinking wine
but also thirst satisfying that but we
could think of all sorts of other things
people who really liked the way that the
fabric that they wear feels and they
have to be dressed in satin or are you
have satin sheets or something like that
right sexual desire and sexual pleasures
fit in there as well and we might think
of all sorts of other things temperance
deals with those temperance involves
self mastery remaining in control when
it comes to those pleasures and desires
so the higher part remains in charge
telling the lower part what to do and
the lower part actually can obey it
interestingly at another point in
talking about the desires or at the
Fumiya themselves Plato will tell us and
I think he's completely correct in this
that they cannot set limits on
themselves we've all had this experience
of eating something at one point in time
and starting to mindlessly eat it and
wanting more and more of it you know for
example people do this with bags of
chips or as they're called in other
places crisps right and you just kind of
start eating bowing down on them as we
say and you know you finished up the bag
and you're like I want more that's your
appetite and hopefully you have another
part of yourself that's saying hey you
ate too many chips knock it off and
that's the other part of yourself says
yeah reason is televi this don't go and
grab another bag of chips but your
appetites let them alone they'll be like
another bag of chips that's that sounds
like a great idea
so the appetites can't control
themselves and if there
restrained if they're not restricted
they will grow larger and larger larger
and this can be a fundamental problem
leading to intemperance
as the vise corresponding to the virtue
of temperance now Plato also makes a
distinction here between not just the
amount of desire or the amount of
pleasure or the action that you engage
in but what you can call the pleasures
and desires of the base the lower the
shameful this is a Greek term meaning
the non noble the non fine right and he
says that we have a mob of motley
appetites and pleasures and pains and he
says something you know a little bit out
of character here one would find chiefly
and children and women and slaves and in
the base rabble of those who are free
men in name you might say well isn't
Plato you know doesn't he think that
women and men are basically the same
when it comes to parts of the soul yes
but he's also talking about ancient
Greek culture where that's not being
acknowledged so generally the things
that women and children and slaves would
indulge in would be seen as sort of
lower-class shameful pleasures and they
wouldn't be enjoying the higher things
likewise he talks about the the rabble
of people who are called free but only a
name they're not really free because
they don't have self-control
they don't master their desires instead
they run around chasing everything so we
can think about all sorts of things in
our own society take away women and
children from it and just think about it
in terms of higher and lower pleasures
does everybody appreciate good food
no there's probably more people out
there who stuff their face with junk
food even though if you actually spend
some time like D you know stripping that
away and then eating actual you know
whole food or well prepared food or
healthy food and you come back to the
junk food you'll be like oh this this
isn't very good at all but you know when
that's what you're used to it's hard to
appreciate the better food and you know
we can say that that the popularity
junk food doesn't make it or fast food
doesn't actually make it better
as a matter of fact it you know it's
it's almost designed to make people
worse not just bodily but in terms of
their appetites and what they take
pleasure so Plato is distinguishing
between these these lower pleasures
these more base pleasures and what he
calls the simple moderate appetites of
the better and so temperance would steer
us away from those and towards better
things so if we think about you know
consuming alcohol I'll give you a prime
example because I you know I don't drink
beer much anymore but I certainly have
done plenty in my life and almost it's
almost a patriotic duty as a you know
residents of the great state of
Wisconsin having grown up here I used to
brew my own beer as well and I know that
you know when I was younger like in high
school and college we would drink
whatever the cheapest stuff we could
find was and it wasn't very good but you
know it was it was okay right and
sometimes people get very very drunk
because there's not much to actually
taste there and then I discovered we
have one of the oldest craft brewing
breweries here in this area
the Sprecher brewery and I discovered
that stuff and then of course I was
overseas in Germany and I got to drink
good beer all the time as a soldier
stationed there and when I came back I
was like who wants to drink this crap
you know I guess if I'm you know I had a
party or something and that's all that's
available I'll drink it but man try this
stuff over here way better you don't
need to drink as much of it because
there's actually more taste more
complexity more interesting stuff right
it's still indulging in the same
modality beer right which is there for
the taste also it's satisfying a thirst
although it makes you thirsty
and it's alcoholic so there's the
intoxication but there's a better and a
worse right and so that's sort of what
Plato's talking about here the last
thing that I want to bring up in this is
he talks about the the need
have a harmony that's almost like a song
there's an analogy going on here and he
it's very nice what he says he says that
the operation of temperance is unlike
that of courage at wisdom which residing
in separate parts made the city one of
them wise and the other brave that's not
the way of temperance or soberness it
extends literally through the entire
gamut throughout bringing about the
unison in the same chant of the
strongest the weakest and the
intermediate whether in wisdom or if you
please in strength or for that matter in
numbers wealth or any similar criterion
we should be right in affirming this
unanimity to be a temperance the Concord
of the naturally superior and inferior
as to which ought to rule both in the
state and in the individual so this
Concord there's you know being unified
being on that literally the same page is
integral to this virtue of temperance
and that so it has to run throughout the
entire soul but it really bears upon the
lowest part of the soul where we find
these appetites for bodily pleasures and
to avoid bodily pains
you